although uncertainties remain in how the
trajectory and the virus itself might
evolve going forwards there is no doubt
that our best bet is to maintain
vigilance we should not forget the
personal protective habits we have
learned as we resume activities and
return to more settings
next week will be the two year
anniversary of the who or world health
organization characterizing covert 19 as
a pandemic since then we have had an
intense apprenticeship in the prevention
control of this new disease
individually and collectively we've
learned so much about how the virus
behaves and what measures work to reduce
the risk of exposure and spreading the
virus by getting vaccinated millions of
canadians have increased their
protection against serious illness and
we have all taken measures to protect
ourselves and others by being aware of
the risks in our communities staying
home when we're sick adjusting plans and
adding other layers of protection such
as wearing masks
now with a strong foundation of
protection from vaccines proven
practices to reduce spread and less
intense pressure on our health system we
need to turn our focus on easing
societal disruption
but regaining in-person social and
economic activities while the pandemic
is still ongoing and the virus is not
going away we means we must use all that
we have learned to do this safely and
make it last
with march break coming up there will be
more opportunities for gatherings travel
and activities
going forward individual risk
assessments can become another one of
our good habits as important and routine
as checking the weather to decide what
activities are best to do and what
essentials to bring with us
regularly checking in on the local
epidemiology where you are or where you
are going is important for keeping up
with recommendations as well as for
making informed decisions on what
precautions to use
in particular if you are traveling this
march break getting up to date with
cover 19 vaccines including getting a
boosted dose if you're eligible and
especially for those aged 50 years or
older is important preparation for safer
activities and travels
and whether or not they are required in
the places or settings you are in mass
remain an important layer of protection
while the virus is still circulating
where mask wearing and other personal
protective practices offer a way for you
and your family to reduce your risk of
exposure and spreading the virus
getting back to more of the people
places and activities we love is
important this is a time of recovery as
well as time to address the broader
impacts of the pandemic while being
ready to respond to future potentially
severe waves by continuing to work
together and supporting those at the
highest risk in our communities we will
be better equipped to work through
future challenges that may come our way
thank you merci migration
19 in hospitals and icus has declined by
over 15 percent
however
the
v2 virus is still circulating widely and
the epidemiological situation is
variable across the country
while some jurisdictions are currently
reporting increased case scouts
ongoing easing of public health measures
could lead to increased transmission in
more areas over the coming weeks
although uncertainties remain in how the
trajectory and the virus itself
might evolve going forward there is no
doubt that our best bet is to maintain
vigilance
we should not forget the personal
protective habits we have learned as we
resume activities and return to more
settings
next week will be the two year
anniversary
that the world health of the world
health organization characterizing
covert 19 as a pandemic
since then we have had an intense
apprenticeship in the prevention and
control of this new disease
individually and collectively we've
learned so much about how the virus
behaves and what measures work to reduce
the risk of exposure and spreading of
the virus
by getting vaccinated millions of
canadians have increased their
protection against serious illness
and we have all taken measures to
protect ourselves and others by being
aware of the risks in our communities
staying home when we are sick
adjusting
now with a strong foundation of
protection from vaccines proven
practices to reduce spread
and
while the pandemic is still ongoing and
the virus is not going away
means that we must use all that we have
learned to do this safely and make it
last
our good habits
regularly checking in on the local
epidemiology
where you are
or where you are going is important for
keeping up with the recommendations as
well as for making informed decisions
on what precautions to use
getting up to date with covert 19
vaccines including getting a booster
dose if you're eligible and especially
for those aged 50 years or older
it's important
remain an important layer of protection
while the virus is still circulating
and other personal protective practices
a way for you and your family to reduce
your risk of exposure and spreading of
the virus
getting back to more of the people
places and activities we love is
important this is a period of recovery
and we well as well as a time to address
the broad issues and
impacts of the pandemic while being
ready to respond to future potentially
severe waves
by continuing to work together and
supporting those that are at the highest
risk in our communities we will be
better equipped to work through future
challenges that may come our way
thank you thank you make witch
thank you doctors for that um
the doctors have quite a bit of time
with us today so i'll try to get through
everyone as quickly as we can so
remember it's one question one follow-up
and we're going to start with adam
harris from the new brunswick telegraph
journal
actually adam we're going to have to
skip you at the moment because it looks
like you're using an older version of
zoom um so
with that in mind uh boss blue from the
dewalt you're up
you spoke at length about wearing masks
and about other personal protective
practices
but what is your thinking about the fact
that quebec and other provinces
have made it no longer mandatory is it
still useful to have a mask mandate
well thank you very much for your
question
i believe that i've already answered
this question before
clearly mask wearing is a well
tested
tried and true personal protective
practice
is it a mandatory requirement
well no it's a personal choice
the measures being played put in place
by various provincial governments
and weighing them up with the
recommendations made by
public health and also individual
choices that one might make
so it's important to continue to inform
the broader public
with the useful and helpful information
and clearly while squaring is an
additional layer of protection
especially for those who are at greater
risk or more susceptible because they're
immunocompromised for example or seniors
so mask wearing is a good layer of
personal protection and you know
sometimes even if they're mandatory or
not mandatory one should not
discriminate or stigmatize those who
choose to continue to wear a mask in
public settings
follow-up question
you talked about the future and that we
should be prepared for future waves
in canada that hits us
could you discuss that please respond
that's a great question and i don't
think it's easy
to come to the conclusion that the
pandemic is over
and to come out and say that but at some
point
we've got to accept that the virus is
here to stay both domestically and
abroad for the
long haul
at least for some time
we need we're reaching a stage where the
mortality rates are becoming manageable
and having a lesser effect on our health
care system
which are managing better and better but
the fact is that we need to continue
with our
effective monitoring systems and the
other tools at our disposal
for example
monitoring waste water
it's important to use those kinds of
indicators to determine whether another
variant of concern may be in the process
of
emerging
for the time being
uh it seems like we're over this omicron
wave but it's always possible that
another variant of concern with even
more serious
ramifications
may come to light
we must remain vigilant
okay up next is crystal oak from global
nation
hi there thank you for taking my
question can you hear me all right
yes oh great um so i just have a couple
questions on ukraine so the immigration
minister has announced a national
interest exemption to allow unvaccinated
and partially vaccinated um ukrainians
to enter canada through specific
programs i was just wondering what is
the protocol at the border of those
coming into canada test positive for
cloven 19 and are there public health
plans in place to accommodate that
because thank you for the question of
course
many government departments are working
together to support the safe entry of
persons leaving the ukraine
i think uh that they will be um asked to
follow the current measures for
vaccinating the unvaccinated travelers
that arrive in canada of course we know
that it's very difficult to get tested
or maybe have the vaccination prior to
arrival in canada but for those who are
unvaccinated they would will be expected
to undergo the usual quarantine measures
and the testing
regiments that are currently in place
and they will be supported in terms of
uh getting uh vaccinated should that be
required
um and as a follow-up so ukraine has a
relatively low cova 19 vaccination rate
are there any new measures or programs
that are going to be introduced for
refugees who would like to be vaccinated
within canada
well i think the programs already exist
and the provinces as well as the federal
government are all very supportive
anyone who isn't vaccinated with the
current uh list of vaccines approved by
health canada or those listed by the who
are all
supported in the provincial territories
to get additional doses as well
okay we're going to move on to
yasmine medi from radio canada
[Applause]
he said that in some provinces it's no
longer mandatory and it'll become a
personal choice
personally speaking are you going to
continue to wear a mask if it's no
longer mandatory in ontario in two weeks
time
do you think it's going to be too soon
to stop wearing a mask what will your
personal choice be well thank you very
much for the question
it's all about performing one's own
individual risk assessment of
determining one's own risk threshold
what one's comfortable with
it's important to look at the regional
pdm
19. and in my case that would be in the
ottawa region
so at least
i'm going to continue to wear a mask for
some time coming uh especially in
enclosed places such as shops stores
even at events that uh returning to full
capacity so personally speaking
as a way of managing risk i'll continue
to wear a mask i'm fully vaccinated
i've also
been boosted so to speak
and so it's important for me
perhaps to continue
to er on the side of caution and use
every layer of personal protection
possible follow up
what about the study on children in new
york about the effectiveness of the fisa
vaccine against omicron
apparently there's been a drop of 12
percent for
five to 11.
were you surprised by these results and
what can that mean here at home in
well it's canada to be important to
continue to follow the findings of
clinical studies and trials on the
vaccines and i'm
absolutely sure that health canada
is
following the situation very closely
of course it's important to analyze
the scientific data on an ongoing basis
and the onus is on the regulators to
undertake their own analysis with a view
to either improving or not improving
certain vaccines but for the time being
i believe that
in the case of the vaccines that are
already available in canada
the science closely especially the
clinical trials
for children under five years of age
maybe i can just take on to that answer
um
we'll see um we're talking about a small
it wasn't a very large study
and a clinic pfizer is in the process of
uh
undertaking a clinical trial for booster
doses
for children between the ages of 5 and
11.
and
perhaps get our hands on those results
pretty soon
just a reminder if anybody wants to have
a question please use the raise hand
function so i can add you to my list if
you already have your hand up you are
there but if you have not done so yet
and you would like a question just
please please do so
with that in mind
up next is mia rabson
from the canadian
yeah uh good afternoon i'm wondering dr
tam if you could talk a little bit about
how much we know about uh sort of the
natural
spread of of coven 19 at this point how
many people have actually had it given
that we haven't really been testing that
widely in the last few months and
whether or not that combined with
vaccines and the high rates of vaccines
we're seeing does give any sense of herd
immunity at this point
yes i think we
are still waiting for some studies
you've seen of what we call zero
prevalence studies so they measure
they sample the population and measure
the antibody levels
using a number of different kind of
tests
to detect antibodies against different
proteins the spike protein and other
proteins
of the virus and you can tell the
difference between those who got the in
immunity perhaps as a result of
vaccination only or also as a result of
infection
we don't have
that many of those at this point for the
pose omicron situation so we will be
looking at that very closely
um and but there are some individual
studies for example in the montreal area
for children and and others that are
being reviewed at the moment and there
has certainly been uh uh quite a large
proportion of individuals who
actually had the infection during the
omicron wave
i do think that if it's omicron that's
circulating in the next months
we have a very good level of protection
in the community particularly with
boosters um protecting against severe
outcomes um but if there's a variant
that's very different omicron then
that's a different story and we'll have
to evaluate the risk
of any vaccine evasive
variants
so there is no
such a thing as a sort of threshold as
it were for her it means at the moment
but i think the level of protection in
the community has got to have
significantly risen in the last months
with increased vaccine coverage and the
infection and that's the same globally
as well
thank you i'm wondering if we also have
any update on the ba2 numbers versus ba1
and whether uh growth of that ba2
variant changes things at all or if it's
similar enough to the original omacron
that it would sort of be covered off
yes so in terms of our understanding of
the characteristics of the ba2 which is
essentially a relative of the omicron
ba1
variant um although there's quite a few
uh differences in the mutations
what the global
uh evidence base has shown is that this
is a variant that can be more um
transmissible potentially but there's no
conclusive information to say that it
causes any more severe outcomes so
that's good news
and
the
the
data to this day suggests that the
vaccine
protectionism is similar between the two
although there's a few studies that
suggest maybe a slight increase in the
immune invasion from the ba2 but
essentially still getting the vaccine
is very important even against ba2 and
against severe outcomes
what we're seeing with
the canadian data is that there's been
increasing proportion of the
identification
of ba2 in our population so um
at the moment uh most vast majority are
still ba1 or we what we call ba 1.1
um and roughly 10 percent
uh are ba2
that's not the same across the country
there are provinces where that
proportion is higher but that's about
where things stand at the moment
domestically
in our international uh monitoring
through the sampling of travelers we're
detecting a higher level at about 20
percent of the proportions
of um travelers with omicron has the ba2
variant
okay uh moving on we're going to go i
want to make sure that we can that
everybody gets a first chance before we
move into potentially second round of
questions
uh with that in mind
we're going to move next to uh
simon bowasa with nouveau info
bonjour
yes good afternoon
dr tam could you please
repeat your answer to my colleague mia
rabson concerning the ba2 ba1 variants
dr tam i can uh step in and uh if you
wish
go ahead go ahead please feel free i'd
always say say doctor new uh wait well
this is dr new here
if i could just sum up dr tam's answer i
don't know if you want the figures
should we still be concerned about the
proliferation of that variant
and what is the public health doing to
monitor
the uh
development
a second cousin if you will
if you look closely at it's defining
characteristics it does strike us being
a tad more transmissible but if you look
at the
issue of
serious consequences
level of protection of vaccines against
ba2 well
the results are very similar to those
for ba1
but of course we're going to continue to
follow it closely
nationwide in a number of provinces in
particular alberta the proportion of ba2
infections is much higher than in other
provinces
it's something that we continue to
continue to monitor closely
the positivity rate is a little bit
higher about 20
among travelers that come to our borders
who
end up with a positive
test for the
ba2
variant thank you very much dr new
follow-up question
i can understand that you're trying to
make canadians
care of themselves personally by
performing individual pers risk
assessments for themselves between the
two of us would you recommend that
canadians avoid travel
whether it be domestically or abroad
what what do you think
in ie should we be allowing them
the choice to make their own decisions
response what we need to
continuously monitor epidemiological
situations both here in canada and
abroad
canada has changed
its advice
regarding travel
for all canadians it used to be
take a close look at where you intend to
go abroad and make your decision on that
basis
perhaps it would be more risky for you
to travel abroad
but it also depends what your
destination country is there's a whole
lot of factors that come into play but
one thing i can tell you
is that there are
it might be a good time to take a trip
south to a warmer destination during the
break
those folks need to be up to date with
their vaccinations
they have to have at least had their two
doses and potentially a booster dose
particularly for those uh 50 years and
older uh comedian
canadians should continue to use all
additional layers of protection at their
disposal mask wearing is an additional
layer of protection which can give
canadians a certain level of confidence
when they choose to engage in activities
both indoors and outdoors and travel
travel abroad but even regardless of
whether or not mask wearing is mandatory
in the destination of choice
but the fact of the matter is
canadians
it's time now to give canadians
the opportunity to
take personal responsibility and to make
their own choices in terms of risk
management both in terms of exposure to
covert 19.
and
whether it comes to traveling
engaging activities or not okay
next up nick bohere from cbc
uh good afternoon doctors just a
question about the provinces which are
moving um in some cases pretty quickly
right now to lift some of these
restrictions um there could be a
situation you know depending on which
province you're in where in the near
future you could go do karaoke at a
packed bar without having to show a
vaccine passport or even be vaccinated
but you couldn't get on a train say and
go to another province is there any risk
from a public health perspective when
you've got canadians living under what
may be quite different rules in the near
future
i think there there is different
epidemiology in different jurisdictions
so i do think that following local
public health advice and
uh watching what that forecast if you
like of activity is in the local
jurisdiction
but when you're talking about
interprovincial transportation that's
that's slightly different and maybe
you're traveling across canada from one
spot that's a hot spot to another spot
that has very little activity so i think
that kind of risk assessment still has
to be undertaken
but i do know that federal government
departments including transport canada
and others are
watching all of the
changes in epidemiology very closely and
we'll be making any policy adjustments
as needed in the coming days and weeks
okay and another question if i can on um
the kids and vaccine topic we've heard
concerns from various public health uh
people around the country about the
relatively lower rate
of vaccination among children uh if
we're moving to this point where a lot
of restrictions are being lifted parents
are maybe less inclined to get their
kids vaccinated what does that say to
you about the outlook for the rest of
the pandemic for the rest of the year if
we have maybe sort of topped out at the
vaccination rate that we're currently at
for kids
yes i think first of all we should
continue to provide information to
parents check out our
videos on talking to experts and seek
out information from your own trusted
experts
to about children's vaccinations so that
is still important
i think
you know having those foundational two
doses is important because if
another variant occurs and you need
another dose and you're starting with
zero
you know that that
that means a lot of time has to be
expended and getting that series uh
started as well so i think that's just
something to bear in mind and and as we
prepare for even the fall season you're
coming out into the spring and summer we
might expect less transmission at least
in the canadian context
but we're all trying to look towards the
fall now where
not only will covid19
potentially increase
in terms of activity but also the other
respiratory viruses
and children are susceptible to many
different respiratory viruses and
you know more protection and different
layers of protection against them will
be very important
i would say you know the the younger the
children
and the under fives we're still waiting
to
have authorization for those vaccines
and especially under one they are even
more susceptible to severe outcomes so
that's something that i think we need to
make sure all parents uh
uh um
you know cognizant of
i do think that as we open up spaces
social economic spaces as people travel
we will expect an increase in cases and
i think that's just
to be expected but people can especially
if their kids have high risk conditions
use many different layers of protection
um particularly getting the adults
around the vaccinated as well as as dr
new and i keep saying mask and other
measures ventilation
etc can help keep our kids safe uh but
yes i mean unvaccinated populations
uh can certainly be
the pockets of uh increased transmission
into the future
okay i'm going to try to go back now to
adam and we'll see if this works and if
not i will ask questions on your behalf
but we're going to go to adam harris
from the telegrapher
thanks jordan um good afternoon thanks
for taking our questions
the federal government's still providing
millions of rapid tests to the provinces
but i was just wondering if there comes
a time when widespread testing
will be phased out or if that's
something that could be continuing for
years
this is teresa tamara i'll try and
answer that question yes so rapid tests
many of them have been developed and
many of them authorize
becomes important tools i do think that
there are periods of ebbs and flows of
use if you like
for them i think i can see going to the
future
so it's
there's there's less value in using them
when activities are low
but there's more value when activities
increase or when you have increased
respiratory infections and you don't
really know what you have then their
appetizers could potentially assist
in telling someone whether they they
have uh covert 19
we have to make sure everyone
understands how to interpret those tests
and the limitations of those tests
to that education is another one of
those um
you know increased measures that we can
take going forwards
so i i don't know the final answer to
your question we will have to keep
watching
the evolution of the virus and the
pandemic but it's great to have that
additional tool
and we can flexibly use it
into the future
if we have to
even if we're not doing
more regular
testing
and with provinces lifting restrictions
does testing regimes become more
important in the interim or not
i think again
they are supplementary to a number of
other measures including the regular
surveillance programs and the regular
pcr testing programs but i think
they are very useful if someone has
symptoms
and you don't know what it is and you're
opening up society and someone has
symptoms then i think the rapid test
could be valuable under those
circumstances
you've seen provinces now beginning to
adapt their testing strategies nova
scotia for instance is now able to
follow up with
pcr confirmatory tests even after a
rapid test because the numbers have come
down a bit so i think these tools will
be used uh in conjunction but i do think
that as provinces are opening up we're
going to be monitoring the wastewater
surveillance we're going to be
monitoring pcr
and the public can
leverage rapid tests
if the activities are sort of going up
in their local environment
well we're going to move on to second
round
and so if you do still have a question
please remember to to raise your hand i
see two up already so
uh we'll start the second round uh
yasmine medi from radio canada
canada when will that measure being in
defect to
what's the time frame
when will we be putting an end to that
federal requirement
this is dr new here
what i can tell you is that we are
closely
at the canadian border
with uh
test positivity rates
the news is good
in the past week at the border
the positivity rate
particularly among travelers
who are fully vaccinated has dropped
substantially
to about 2.8
this is really good it's much lower than
it was previously
and it's something that we will factor
in
going forward
as you speak
when we consider making adjustments
i know that there's no longer
requirement to take a pcr test to come
back to canada it's a rapid antigen test
how can you justify that measure
knowing that
these rapid tests are not really
reliable
what the criteria are you basing your
decisions on
responses
well thank you very much for your
question
to
arriving in canada is another layer of
protection for canadians
that positivity
we're continuing to monitor the
situation
and
monitor our policies
so stay tuned we'll continue to make our
recommendations to decision makers
and rely on scientific data in doing so
up next mia rabson from the canadian
yeah hi again um i'm just wondering
you've talked a little bit about what
needing to put sort of make your own
choice about wearing a mask if it's no
longer mandated i'm wondering if you
could just talk from your own experience
or your own plans how long you would
intend to wear a mask or what might
might convince you that a mask isn't
necessary uh anymore
for yourselves
maybe like dr tam go first i think i
answered it in france i think that's a
new answer in front so yeah so i think
uh first of all looking at the activity
level in
the community that i'll be i'm living in
or i'm visiting so
i know that in ottawa for example the
level of activities going down so that's
good news
uh then i look at well what activity am
i undertaking is it outside is inside is
it crowded who am i going to be with
and i'll still be taking those kind of
evaluations
uh i'll take into account my own
personal medical underlying medical
conditions but also the fact that i have
elderly parents for example i may want
to protect them more so therefore i'm
not going to take as many chances and i
if i visit them i might
wear a mask depending on the activity so
i think it is very personalized but i do
think that uh as the omicron wave comes
down um there'll be much more
opportunities for people
to feel more comfortable in in removing
the mask i know that i've been
vaccinated and boosted
so um personally i feel quite well
protected against severe outcomes so
i'll take that into account for sure
it's dr new i just maybe that to what i
i said in french similar to dr tama
certainly every time i leave i leave the
house uh as we actually said in our
opening remarks uh you would you know
just like you would look at the weather
forecast before you go and make sure
that you're properly you know sort of a
dress to have the appropriate quote
equipment which you need before you go
out
depending on the weather same thing now
uh you know depending on whether i'm
going to let's say a crowded location
indoors let's say for shopping as
opposed to maybe an outdoor activity
that would certainly uh you know factor
into you know whether i would feel it
necessary or appropriate for my risk to
to wear a mask or not and then
like i said uh i think in french also in
terms of you know the the
possibility of traveling outside the
country i think many canadians are are
looking at that as they as they go down
maybe south or to other locations and
it's the same thing you know you need to
look at your own personal situation your
risk factors and then obviously look at
the situation and where you're going
what's the epidemiology like how how
widely is the virus circulating in your
destination as opposed to uh where
you've come from and then of course uh
look at what kind of activities you're
going to be doing if you're going to be
spending most of your time outdoors
maybe you know hiking and you know
without too much contact with other
people that that's a different kind of
risk compared to uh uh recognizing that
you're maybe going to a a sort of a a
vacation outside the country where you
will be mostly indoors you know uh maybe
uh you know bar hopping or whatever
where there could be lots of people
indoors etc and so on so i think it's
all a matter of taking all those factors
in account and then obviously uh you
know based on your own risk tolerance uh
whether you would want to continue
wearing a mask or not in those
circumstances
one other point that i think dr new
mentioned in french that i think is is
actually
important to repeat is
actually showing compassionate and
support for others
i think um you know whether you decide
to wear a mask or not think about who
you're with and maybe they're at higher
risk so
uh having that consideration for others
do not stigmatize people who do wear a
mask
um or indeed there's maybe very good
reasons why you don't need to wear a
mask under certain circumstances
and so people need to be patient as we
begin to learn
uh to come out of that crisis phase into
uh into more of a longer term ongoing
management on kobe 19. it's not going to
be easy and putting on a specific
measure is sometimes hard and for people
to follow what public health is asking
them to do but once a habit is developed
we hope that this just becomes part of
your routine
respiratory virus precautions that you
would take with you um on an ongoing
basis but it is not going to be easy i
can see there are tensions
there are fears from those with
underlying risk factors that they're
going to be going to spaces where people
are not respecting
those layers of protection anymore so i
think i would ask everyone to be really
patient with each other during this time
of transition
you said earlier in your opening remarks
that it's sort of time to ease some of
the societal disruptions but we might
have to be prepared again if things
change or if another variant comes up
but i also remember it was you or others
saying when omicron came that this
wasn't march 2020 we've learned a lot we
know a lot more and yet our response was
very similar the same kind of closures
schools closures business closures
those same very disruptive societal
changes
what can we expect if there's another
variant do we have the ability to make
choices or restrictions that aren't as
severe as what we've seen so far
well i think that is the goal
public health
systems across the countries really want
to minimize
those really restrictive measures but
they may ask people to wear a mask again
for example for indoor settings
so
using some of those
measures i think what has been really
difficult to balance this reduction of
severe outcomes against societal
disruption
is the fragility of the health care
system
so i think during this time of recovery
it's really important to look at health
human resource
and show up that
hospital
you know infrastructure
your long-term care
infrastructure and preparedness
of course the public health system
itself needs to recover as well
but it was really difficult because of
hospitals filling up again
and uh the concern that maybe icu's will
it just so happens omicron is has has
less severe impacts
and we've been more vaccinated but i do
think we've got more treatment options
now
we've got
vaccines and we will know more what to
do with different kinds of boosters
and we have rapid tests which even at
the beginning of the omin crime wave
wasn't that widely
deployed but it escalated
and so i think with all of those
measures and understanding viral
transmission wearing a mass
ventilation etc we've got to be able to
go into the fall and winter season or
indeed the next wave if you should come
in between with much more ability
to respond without those really severe
restrictions that is the goal but you
know we still need to be flexible with
the suite of measures should it become
necessary and it's very different for
example i think in different areas of
canada where the health care system
capacity may differ
and that's why i think you saw or even
right at the beginning
some of the smaller jurisdictions taking
more measures because they simply can't
afford to have a rapid escalation in
their health
care
system impacts
so it is very difficult but i am
optimistic and and we work with the
provinces to
see if if we couldn't we you know make
make sure that balance
uh is maintained and improved upon
i know we've gone through two rounds um
i i as moderator i'm going to use my
my privilege here to ask a question too
just to follow up on something you just
said dr cam which is
shoring up the health care system i'm
wondering if you can elaborate a bit
about how much has been done to do that
maybe in since the in the two years as
you point out since we've entered this
pandemic but also maybe how much more
still needs to be done in your mind
before
you could say mission accomplished
yes and that's of course quite a big
question which
you know the
decision makers need to grapple with
i do know that
a lot of work is being done right now to
look at
the strengthening of healthcare systems
in many ways i think the biggest
need is in the hell human resource
particularly when
the health teams are so exhausted
and so
i think there are many different
avenues of exploration
and i'm not really the lead on the
healthcare system so i'm going to have
to point you back towards health canada
and
the the minister himself maybe to take
those questions
but we have learned quite a lot um
one is i think looking at the surge
capacity requirements
i really feel that the partnership with
the canadian red cross for example has
been particularly important they played
a really big role in providing surge as
needed
but there's an as a finite number even
of that resource the federal government
itself provided our own staff to some of
these situations
and as you can appreciate the canadian
armed forces cannot just keep surging
they've got many other priorities that
you've seen globally with different
activities right now that that's taking
up their
area of focus so training um
requirements looking at licensures
um with the regulatory bodies across the
country on um
really uh making sure that we've
considered how we leverage uh
um international graduates
and and
credentialing uh different health
professionals in that area all of these
come into play i think
and
this is a subject that is of great
importance but i might not be the
most
knowledgeable about that the other thing
is uh virtual care
is
you know has become um
a real reality and was boosted during
the pandemic so knowing how to best use
that
for
going forwards i think would be very
important as well
uh thank you for that i
we still have just a few minutes and i
know there's only a few people left on
the line so if anybody has one final
question
you can raise use the raised hand
function and i will squeeze you in now
seeing none
i think we can wrap up for today uh dr
tam dr new thank you very much for your
time as always thank you to everyone for
joining us that concludes today's press
conference
thank you thank you merci bond fenceman
enjoy your weekend